[Music]
straight ahead
on lawn crime daily vanessa bryan
settles with the helicopter company for
the deadly crash that killed kobe bryant
their daughter and seven others
and former nickelodeon star drake bell
pleads guilty
then takes to instagram to play for his
fans
[Music]
plus a trial date now set for doomsday
defendant chad daybell
and a mother's grief on display in a
colorado courtroom
as she searches for her missing son i
was stressed out because i didn't know
where my son was
his father mark redwine now on trial for
murder plus
the latest in the trial of robert durst
the real estate heir accused of
murdering his best friend
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
vanessa bryant and the families of the
other crash victims are settling their
wrongful death lawsuit against a
helicopter company
behind the crash that killed nine lives
including kobe bryant
and his daughter gianna a year and a
half after the deadly helicopter crash
that killed nba legend kobe
bryant his daughter gianna and seven
others one of the lawsuits
is now resolved vanessa bryan sued
island express helicopters
its owner and the estate of the pilot
now they've appeared to reach a
settlement
in court documents filed on tuesday
attorneys for brian filed a joint notice
of settlement and request to vacate
discovery deadlines
details of the settlement are
confidential and it still needs to be
approved by the court
an accident is something that is
unforeseen
unpredictable if you will unfortunately
this wasn't
the us government is a third party in
the suit and is not appearing to settle
in the document attorneys say that this
settlement does not apply to any cross
claims filed by the helicopter company
against the government the ntsb
concluded earlier this year
that decisions made by the pilot during
the flight led to the helicopter crash
he didn't follow any of the
recommended uh mitigations
for uh entering uh instrument
meteorological conditions
or to properly once he had entered them
configured the aircraft
by slowing down by starting a climb
by activating the autopilot none of that
happened
terry so as we said the motion says the
parties will settle but it doesn't
actually include
the third part of the united states it
actually asks for discovery in
that regard to continue what do you make
of that you know brian it's not uncommon
when you have a civil
lawsuit to have some of the parties
settle and to keep some of the claims
open particularly if there are cross
claims involved and here it looks as
though
this united states is saying as a
government entity
that they aren't responsible and so
they're probably holding out they want
the discovery
to support their claim so i'm not
surprised that several parties have
settled
and that the united states is waiting to
see what the discovery
comes to say now terry maybe i'm
grasping at straws here but in my mind
vanessa bryant absolutely had the
resources to keep this lawsuit going
do you think settling now was probably
in the best interest of all the
plaintiffs
i do brian and i think even if you have
all of the resources to pursue a
wrongful death action as vanessa is
doing here
it's still very emotional and it's very
draining to pursue something like that
you know she's filed this suit and there
would be
a ton of evidence and she'd have to
relive the incident
and discuss the very difficult details
about all of the passengers last moments
particularly her daughter and her
husband
so i think if you can come to a
resolution and it's a resolution that
is satisfactory to the parties involved
or at least most of the parties involved
i think that makes sense absolutely
we've seen a lot of cases like this
where there's such an emotional drain in
the case itself that many
especially the victims look to settle
before having to relive that trauma
thank you terry turning now to other top
legal news
former nickelodeon star drake bell pled
guilty to crimes against a minor
then took to instagram to sing for his
four million followers
how do you plead to count one attempted
endangering children fell into the
fourth degree
guilty how do you plead to count two
disseminated matter
harmful to juveniles first-degree
misdemeanor guilty
jared drake bell pled guilty to two
charges related
to a 2017 incident with a then
15-year-old at one of his concerts
prosecutors say the teen had established
a relationship with bell
several years prior mr bell how old are
you
currently 34. how far did you go in
school
um ged are you undergoing psychiatric
treatment
i mean i've seen a psychologist i don't
know if that's psychiatric treatment
a grand jury indicted bell earlier this
month and he's been out on jail on bond
he appeared virtually in court to enter
his plea at his arraignment
all right how about an oldie but a good
minutes after court ended
bell lost the tie-in jacket and took to
instagram
[Music]
bell who now goes by drake campana was
on the nickelodeon sitcom drake and josh
he played the song's theme song for his
fans which he wrote
he is currently a spanish language
singer based out of mexico
he faces up to 18 months in prison for
the top charge he's due back in court
next month for sentencing
that was a 35 minute video that was
posted on his instagram still
there about 250 000 people have viewed
it so far
we'll see how that is taken into
consideration when it goes to sentencing
later in july
and in idaho a trial date has now been
set for one of the defendants of the
so-called
doomsday cult couple chad daibel and his
wife lori are charged with the murders
of lori's two children and chad's first
wife tammy
officials say the couple believes in a
doctrine to rid the world of zombies
and the human bodies they inhabit lori's
case is on hold for now as she's been
deemed incompetent to stand trial due to
mental health concerns
chad's case is moving forward the judge
set the start of his trial date for
november 8.
it's expected to last five weeks chad is
pleading not guilty to all
charges against him prosecutors have not
yet said if they'll seek the death
penalty
if he's convicted so
terry chad dabell is going to be tried
first and
alone do you think this changes anything
for the prosecution's trial strategy
where prior to this they thought they
would have both the day bills being
uh tried together right brian i think
that
if the trial goes alone and ahead with
chad
and we know that that's the case so far
the prosecution is definitely going to
have to pivot
together if they had been tried together
we would be able to see chad pointing
the finger at laurie
maybe lori pointing the finger back but
now i think we're going to see chad
saying listen i had nothing to do with
it
it was either laurie's idea or it was
alex you know laurie's deceased
brother and it just so happened that jj
and tyler's remains were found in my
backyard but i knew
nothing about it so if he gets up on the
stand
he could very well convince the jury of
that and i think it's going to be
very difficult for the prosecution
because at that point
if the jury determines that chan is not
guilty
we know already that laurie has been
found not competent to stand trial so
that's going to put the prosecution in a
very difficult position
if that plays out like that terry am i
reading this right are you saying that
this decision to go forward alone may
help out
chad dabel for this trial absolutely and
that's my opinion i definitely think it
could help all right we'll see how it
plays out and see if he even takes a
stand to do just as you suggested
still ahead on law and crime daily what
former officer derek shovin can expect
when he's sentenced this week but first
the victim's mother takes the stand in
the trial of mark redwine
her heart-wrenching testimony as she
learns her son is missing
and what her ex-husband told her
[Music]
emotional testimony of the trial of mark
redwine as dylan redwine's mother takes
the stand and tells the jury about the
last time she saw her son
law and crime angela levy is here with
what she said
brian elaine hall told the jury that her
divorce
from mark redwine was contentious most
are and she explained what happened
right before dylan went missing and
afterwards
dylan was sweet he was funny he was
charismatic
elaine hall describing her youngest son
to the jury
she said dylan did not want to visit his
father but was required to do
so because of a court order that was one
of dylan's biggest complaints is when he
would go
to viceto they would basically just sit
in mark's house
and dylan would be incredibly bored
paul read a text message that she sent
to dylan the morning after he arrived
how's it going son you okay hall said
dylan didn't respond and she never heard
from dylan again
after he landed to visit his father the
night before
hall became increasingly concerned after
receiving a text from mark redwine
asking her whether she'd seen dylan she
texted mark redwine back
have you heard anything from dylan you
said you called the marshall's office
they have no record of you calling them
i called them
countless searches took place for dylan
elaine hall said she provided dylan's
clothing and a pillowcase for search
dogs to have his scent
hall testified about appearing on dr
phil to bring attention to her son's
disappearance
in june 2013 part of his remains were
found on middle mountain road
dylan's girlfriend also testified he was
amazing
like he always had a smile on his face
he
he if you were upset he would ride in
your day
kristen baird echoed testimony that
dylan did not want to visit his dad
how did dylan see him about visiting his
friends
that's all he cared about what do you
mean that's the only reason he wanted to
come to durango
but mark redwine's attorney questioned
her about dylan's feelings about the
trip
do you recall telling dylan that you
were scared
of him making the trip yes
and you recall that dylan told you not
to be scared
yeah he told you quote
it was going to be fine yes
now the prosecutor asked elaine hall
whether or not dylan had any injuries to
his
face before he went to visit his father
she said he did not have any injuries to
his face and we are expecting to hear
testimony later in the trial
about blunt force trauma injuries to
dylan's skull
brian interesting and jeanette the
defense questioned elaine hall
about both her relationship with her ex
and the actions of dylan
when uh uh when he went missing can you
elaborate on that
yeah uh they questioned she was
questioned about
her actions after dylan went missing she
was asked you know you went on dr phil
you went on true crime podcast
and she said yeah she did all of those
things and she spoke with the media she
said she was trying to raise awareness
about her son's case and she wanted to
bring her son home
and she was also you know saying look
yeah i suspected him because he wasn't
being cooperative
and they were basically trying to say
that you know she basically
cast this cloud of suspicion over her
ex-husband
and maybe didn't look at other
possibilities making sense definitely
makes him look very guilty especially
based on his actions not really
what most parents would do terry the
defense tried to keep them out but the
text messages between mark and hall came
in
what did they reveal about mark redwine
you know i think there were several
consistent themes here brian first of
all we know that dylan did not want to
spend time
with his father and what that tells the
jury is they had a very negative
bad relationship for whatever reason and
it also tells us
that mark was being evasive as angenette
said
he wasn't directly answering questions
he said that he had called the
authorities when in fact he had not and
she confirmed
that so it's a very serious red flag
when you have one parent
who was last with the child who isn't
talking about
when and where and how that occurred and
when you are being evasive about calling
the authority so
i definitely think that one of the
themes that the prosecution is showing
here
is the fact that this parent the
defendant
was not being forthright with his wife
absolutely a big motive that the
prosecution is planting in this case and
i think it's working pretty well
and a number of questions have been
asked about dylan hitchhiking
what did dylan's mom say about that yeah
she said that you know she would see
these cases on the news and she always
had this fear
of you know losing a child because she
would see kids go missing on the news
and she became aware of that one
instance
during a blizzard a snowstorm when dylan
and his friends
hitchhiked they were cold it was snowy
and she said they were in the bed of the
truck not the cab of the truck
and she was not happy about him doing
that but she said this was not something
that she was aware of him doing
regularly and uh the defense kind of
questioned her about that as well
because the defense is suggesting
he very well may have hitchhiked to go
to one of his friends and something bad
may have happened
yeah absolutely an argument the defense
is trying to push forward but still
heart-wrenching testimony
hearing that of a mother talk about her
missing child thank you both
coming up on law and crime daily a
retired lapd detective
takes a stand in the robert durst murder
trial and the shocking end to one of his
friend's testimony
plus how derek truman's life behind bars
will change
after his sentence here from a current
inmate and a former prison warden
[Music]
next
now to minnesota where derek shogun
faces decades in prison
when he's sentenced this friday chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
is digging into what the former
minneapolis police officer
can expect for his first time behind
bars
thanks brian to get an idea of what life
might be like for derek chauvin
behind bars we talked to a former prison
warden
and to a current inmate now serving time
i
have to say that his experience would be
terrible uh he would be an instant
target
awesome so the national security prisons
are obviously
uh on the inmate front are ran by gang
they're gonna send somebody after them
automatically they're gonna send
somebody to stab
him or a couple people to beat him up so
for derek sheldon it's gonna be um
clearly it's gonna be worse he's gonna
go in people are gonna recognize him
instantly
and i would uh jeez i i hate to say this
but i would say that
you're probably going to try to kill him
to get more on this we're now joined by
a former warden
cameron lindsay who served in the
federal system across the country and
also in
a number of private prisons let's begin
by having your description of what
happens to police officers when they end
up
behind bars police officers have to be
treated very carefully when they come
into the system
for uh safety and security purposes uh
one could argue that derek chavin is
america's most
hated person so therefore the minnesota
department of corrections
will will have a challenge in in terms
of ensuring his
his safety and security and do you think
there'll be inmates who will be out to
get him
i don't think there's any question about
it um he is just too big of a target
and so nuts and bolts what does a warden
do in that situation
nuts and bolts brian i i believe that uh
unequivocally they're going to have to
place him in some type of protective
custody stat
uh he will be in in some type of um
some type of of isolation uh solitary
confinement if you will
will he will he will expect to be locked
down
probably 23 hours a day with with one
hour a day devoted
to recreation but they they being the
minnesota doc
does have a responsibility to safeguard
him and i think the only way to do that
is is to keep him single-celled
throughout the duration of his
incarceration
so this is going to be very hard time
for derek sheldon
it really is it's going to be hard time
and the thing about solitary confinement
is i i used to be a believer
in it and used it at times but i i do
not believe in it any longer
for any kind of long-term purposes
unquestionably
uh it causes uh mental illness and those
who
already have mental illnesses it
exacerbates those mental illnesses
hard times ahead for derek shopin this
is brian ross for the law and crime
trial network
thanks brian be sure to tune in this
friday i'll be heading to minneapolis to
bring you the sentencing hearing
for derek chauvin when we come back the
latest in the trial of robert durst
the revelation that left one of dura's
closest friends speechless
and a detective takes on durham's
handwriting when law and crime daily
continues
welcome back testimony from one of
robert durst's close friends
wraps up in his murder trial durst is
accused of murdering his friend susan
berman
emily altman took the stand in
pre-recorded testimony altman is the
wife of stuart altman
a former attorney and friend of robert
durst toward the end of her testimony
prosecutor john lewin
told her who will inherit durst estate
once durst dies
[Music]
[Music]
next a retired los angeles police
detective took the stand
he says durst made a conscious effort to
change his handwriting when he asked for
a sample by police
well when he was instructed to write
in cursive everything was fine he would
write it
when it came time to do printing it
seemed like he was
slow and deliberate
and would almost write the letters
in reverse like going
instead of clockwise writing them in
counterclockwise
almost like he had been rehearsed or
practicing this
see now this goes to the investigation
of the cadaver note that durst now in mr
writing
terry did the inheritance of dura's
estate create
i don't know maybe more motive for his
friends to perhaps cover up for him or
how do you think we're supposed to
interpret this
oh absolutely it was an excellent point
that lauren made there
if in fact either emily or stewart her
husband
or anyone else is going to inherit the
estate
it is incentive for them to defend him
to the very bitter end
and we've seen all of his friends
exactly do that i mean we saw
douglas oliver on the stand arguing with
lewin and defending him
and we've seen that emily altman is also
a huge defender of durst
she stuck with him no matter what she
had her son
be the uh individual who
durst ultimately was the godfather for
even though she knew
he was involved in these murders so i
definitely think that
emily and anyone else who is a dear
friend of durst
they are going to stick up for him and
defend him particularly if in fact
they are going to inherit part of that
estate yeah i kind of like what lewin's
doing here he's making durst look like
the puppet master of all
his friends looking after him but he cut
the string of susan berman because she
wasn't playing along
it makes sense now durst admitted to
writing the cadaver note so
does the testimony about the writing
sample give the jury more
oh absolutely i think that cadaver note
is one of the most important pieces of
information
first he denied writing the note then
you heard
the fact that he pretended to have
different type of handwriting in terms
of the slant of his hand
then he admitted that he actually did
write the note so i think that his
behavior here is definitely
deceptive and i think the jury is going
to pick up on that it's beyond
consciousness
guilt it is deceptive yeah that
deception part not just the admission
that he
wrote the note makes a lot of sense
terry thank you and thank you for
joining us here at law on crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you